Some languages have freakishly long words.
Hawaiian driver's licenses have
literally chopped off people's names.
When ancient comedians spelled out this
mystery meat dish and German words can
get so hefty that even when they lost
their longest one in 2013 it hardly left a
dent.
So what's going on and these words
and just how long can a word get?
A couple of years ago, I was living the
life chained to a desk, 10 hours a day,
working weekends, taking lunch breaks
to go snorkel with turtles in the reef.
Oh, did I not mention I was
chained to a desk in Hawaii,
so I had a good swim and I'm walking
back and I must have zoned out on the
scenery,
eve singing with the birds or something
because somewhere I took a wrong turn
and now I am face to face with the
street sign that never quits. Seriously,
those letters went on forever. If
you're a normal human in this situation,
you know you're lost. You turn
around and you walk the other way.
But language nerds, we drop our ice cream
and sit there mesmerized by phonemes.
Oh wait,
you think a lone male goes wandering
the streets looking at ice cream cone?
That is creepy. No, we'd shave ice.
The kicker though is if you
pop open a Hawaiian dictionary,
you won't find these forever
words. In fact, most terms,
we'll look downright short. So where
are the extra letters coming from?
Hanging out with me long enough.
And you'll hear about Pacific island
taboos in Hawaii. The word is couple. Oh,
and there are some intriguing copper
stories, but that's for later.
So keep capule.
But now go and grab this sounds hollow,
which my grammar book calls a causative,
smashed that onto Capua
and you'll get whole.
It'd be make something
holy or cause to be taboo.
But these affixes only bias a few
characters and they give me grammatical
headaches.
So no big wins here besides most Hawaiian
grammar is done with separate little
words called particles.
And if you thought dissecting
word beasts was a pain,
here's your chance to tame a bunch
of little scurrying word insets.
So beautiful though.
But what's better than taking your base
word and growing it by sticking on some
appendages. Adding another base
word. This is called compounding.
Edit a you some serious extra letters.
What she got got a brain.
How about a lightening brain dumb.
Here's some Pele dog trigger fish.
Why not a blunt pig snout trigger fish.
[inaudible]
pressive word building Hawaii.
So then it's Hawaii home
to the longest word ever.
It is not.
What about German or Greek from earlier?
Same strategy.
Compound compound compound. No
record breakers. They're either,
unfortunately the award
goes to Durham role,
a master compounder, extraordinary.
A 16th century writer, Fetal Mulamba.
She used compounding in her sand script
masterwork in which there is an entire
chapter devoted to basically just saying,
so this guy pass through a part of Tamil
Nadu but she gushed over that region.
I mean she really laid it on thick one.
Just one of the litany of flowery Sanskrit
words she use to describe the place
contains dozens and dozens of compounds,
and that is how a sense grid compound
made the Guinness World Records for
longest word.
And we having a moment here is that
thought crossing your mind to like,
theoretically,
couldn't we just keep adding and
adding hyphenated compounds infinitely.
Hope you're right. Kind of
unfair then, Huh? If that's
how we're playing this, fine.
It's a hyphenated verbal arms race.
The thing about words like these is
they don't really get used. Truth is,
even with compounding,
Hawaiian and German and even Sanskrit
aren't winning any average word length
awards around the world.
Languages where people actually use long
words and nearly every single sentence,
oh, they build words very differently.
She'd come back to that sometime.
Stick around and subscribe for language.